[Music]
this afternoon from target field the
final game of a short regular season in
advance of the postseason cincinnati
reds are going to the playoffs so too
are the minnesota twins looking for win
number 37
on the air and the twins are in control
of their destiny they're ahead of the
white sox by a game in the american
league central standings and two games
clear of the cleveland india
and rich hill ready to go
ridge hill made his way back from a
elbow procedure and throwing the ball
well in the month of september aristides
aquino leading things off
and a breaking ball
gets strike three
and avila to suno and that completes the
strikeout one down
one down and that'll bring up
castigliano's
strike three to castianos who squawks at
tim timmons
two down two strikeouts for rich hill
one swinging one looking right hander
sonny gray second appearance since
returning from the injured list you know
there are two pitchers in the red's
rotation where you up the
level of intensity a little bit when
they get on the mountain i'm not so sure
that sunny gray is all that fast far
behind trevor bauer he may not shout
down the other hitters but man oh man he
is ready to go when he takes the mound
and the banner is luisa rise
this one off the hands of gray
bare-handed play and a dandy
turned in by the rookie jose garcia well
he is everything as advertised from a
defensive standpoint garcia has played
tremendous defense for the reds when
he's had a chance to be on the field
lead off man aboard for the reds and
there's nick sends out
bouncer to short how many
one
two a double play neatly turned polanco
to her eyes to cenote starts with the
good footwork from polanco chest high
feed and then good exchange perfectly
turn double play miguel cino has had
some success off of sonny gray three for
nine a couple of home runs
six up six down for sonny gray we're
scoreless 3-2 now he'll face jose garcia
high fly center field and deep
going back his cave he's at the warning
track at the wall when he makes the
catch
410 feet away from home plate
garcia hit it to the wrong part of the
ballpark
i believe we've seen him in a week
ball's not carrying to right
nine up nine down for sonny gray
joey vado will lead off the fourth
inning
my ball left center field
cave drifting back still going back
staying with it and making a nice catch
on the track that ball kept on carrying
and cave ended up doing kind of a circle
route out there but he stayed under it
and made the catch sunny gray is back to
work for the reds strike three called a
fastball at the knees and sonny gray has
his first strikeout of the afternoon and
he punches out max kepler the reds will
be the seventh seed and will go to
atlanta to face the braves
farmer what a play garcia they've got
two big leagues double play farmer
garcia turn it
one and one
high pop up
deep short short left center
and cave is coming in and a collision
and i think rosario caught the ball
everybody's okay
inning over bottom of the fifth still no
score
well you got a strikeout waiting to
happen up there with ceno and he gets it
he called it right on cue
strikeout number 89 for miguel cino need
a two-out hit here for marwan gonzalez
[Applause]
and strike three called and the twins
are calling they're calling a block
gray didn't stop and now here comes the
cincinnati bench
the twins squawked for a block saying
granted come to a stop and eventually
home plate umpire tim timmons
falls the bar it'll be aquino
got it
back inside clipped the corner with a
fastball one away
whistler v suarez
suarez
into right center field and that will
fall
on his way to third is vato they're
going to wave him around as they have
trouble handling the baseball out there
the reds have tied it up little fastball
up and into suarez he knows he gets it
but not good enough to leave the yard
and there it falls
two strikes to rosario
driven to right center field going back
as castellanos
and he will make the catch at the wall
everyone moves up 90 feet
and that means it's two to nothing twins
on an o2 pitch rosario got the job done
that's the switch hitting freddie galvez
who will now hit for jose garcia
galvez
right field and that will fall and
that'll bring home the tying run freddie
galvez comes off the bench and delivers
an rbi hit brand new game first and
third now for the reds
line drive base hit
scoring is lorenzen they're going to
hold up casalli and tucker barnhart with
a clutch hit in the 10th to give the
reds the lead
ball four and romo walks in a run
insurance coming to the plate 4-2 reds
bases loaded one out
swung on base hit this will score
another
5-2 reds
that's to center and a base hit
rounding third and they're going to send
the runner on
lorenzo and the twins have one back and
now that just like that the tying run
gets to the plate jay ray adrianza will
get her to bat here 0-2 pitch
strike three called he struck him out
and the reds win the finale of the 2020
season 5-3 your final score